-On Monday night, my next guests
became Stanley Cup champions.
From the 2020 Stanley Cup
champion Tampa Bay Lightning,
here are team captain
Steven Stamkos,
Nikita Kucherov,
and MVP Victor Hedman!
Congratulations, guys,
on winning the Stanley Cup.
Steven, how did you guys
celebrate on Monday night?
You don't have to
go into full detail.
-Yeah, I don't know.
You name it, we did it.
We -- This is the greatest
trophy in all of sports,
but You can make whatever
the heck you want out of it.
-[ Laughs ]
-There it is right there.
We were drinking everything
out of there.
You see the boys are drinking
in the background still.
-Oh, my God.
They're troublemakers.
Oh -- [ Laughs ]
Now, obviously you guys --
It's a tough sport.
Players get hit in hockey.
Nikita, you got hit more times
than usual
in just one game against Dallas.
We have video of this.
Take a look at this.
-...runs into Jamie Benn.
-Bop! Right there.
That was enough for me.
And then -- Oosh!
That's when I started crying.
And here's -- Bang!
Right in the head.
Now, do you know
where you are right now?
-Yeah. Yeah.
It was a tough
first period for me.
But, you know,
you have to stick to the game
and do whatever you can
to help the guys be in the game
and help them to win.
-You're a tough --
-It doesn't matter what happens.
You know, guys getting hit,
guys getting back, sacrifice --
sacrifice their body.
It's part of the playoffs.
-Steven, as the captain,
what do --
You're in game five.
And it's double OT.
Here's my theory.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Do you go like, "Hey, guys,
let's just get rid of this,
give them the game tonight,
we'll get a good night's sleep,
and then we're going to come out
and kill them on game six"?
Is that a theory at all or no?
-You got it, Jimmy.
You could do my job no problem.
-Thank you, thank you.
That's all I wanted to hear.
-That was it.
I mean, the Cup was in
the building for game five.
You can't not think about it.
And then to lose
in double overtime,
we just told the guys, like,
we played great, keep going.
I think that was the best game
we've ever played, was game six.
-Yeah. I agree.
Victor, you won MVP.
How does it feel
to be better than everybody?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I don't know about that.
-No, I just wanted to get
a reaction from the guys.
How does it feel
to be named MVP?
It's got to feel good.
-Yeah, that was unbelievable.
I did not expect it at all.
And, you know,
at the end of the day,
the Cup you play for
is obviously this one.
So, this could have gone to each
and every one on this team.
But, you know, having my name
on this Cup means the world.
-What is the first name
that you look at
when you look
at the Stanley Cup?
-I think, like,
Wayne Gretzky, for us,
for my generation coming up.
You see that name,
it's -- it's all over the Cup.
So it's -- It was pretty funny.
He actually FaceTimed
Patrick Maroon after the game,
and The Great One was there.
-Wow.
-Unbelievable
to have that moment.
So that --
I thought that was pretty cool.
-I have to say,
in times like this, you know,
we're looking for
any good news at all.
We need good news.
We need things to celebrate.
And you guys gave us
something to celebrate,
and you gave us some good news.
So thank you so much for that
as a fan.
And congrats again
on winning the Stanley Cup.
-Thanks, Jimmy!
-Steven Stamkos,
Nikita Kucherov,
and Victor Hedman.
Thank you so much
for being here.